mind your decisions i'm presh toewalker
a cube with edges of length 10 contains
nine identical spheres as shown
one sphere is in the center of the cube
above it are four spheres that are
tangent to it and tangent to each of the
four corners of the cube
below it is another layer of four
spheres that are tangent to the center
sphere and tangent to the four corners
of the cube
what is the radius of each sphere pause
the video if you'd like to give this
problem a try and when you're ready keep
watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
the key to solving this problem is to
look at the geometry from the right
perspective
rather than analyzing all nine spheres
we will make one great simplification
we will only consider the position of
three spheres along the diagonal of the
cube
we will then calculate the length of the
diagonal of this q
suppose we have a cube
to do this we will consider the
following right triangle
suppose the cube has an edge length
equal to s
then the bottom face will have a
diagonal that has a length s times the
square root of 2.
then the long diagonal can be calculated
using your favorite theorem
this results in the length of s times
the square root of 3.
if s is equal to 10 we have the
following dimensions
we will then calculate the length of the
long diagonal in terms of the radius of
each sphere
from the bottom sphere we have a cube
that forms between the center of that
sphere and the corner of the cube
this cube will have a length equal to
the radius of the sphere which means its
long diagonal will be equal to r times
the square root of 3.
we then have a length here equal to r
we then have a diameter equal to 2r
we then have a radius equal to r and we
then have another distance from the
center of the sphere to the corner of
the cube which will be equal to r times
the square root of 3.
the entire distance will be equal to r
multiplied by the quantity four plus two
times the square root of three
and this is equal to ten times the
square root of three
we can thus solve for r
and to simplify things we'll multiply by
the conjugate
we thus get that r is equal to the
following which simplifies to be 10
times the square root of 3 minus 15 and
that's approximately equal to 2.32
incredible
thanks for making mind your decisions
one of the best channels on youtube
see you next episode as we continue our
quest to solve the world's problems one
video at a time
[Music]